the building blocks of our universe from
atoms to fundamental particles follow
behave according to the rules of quantum
physics those are very different from
the rules of your everyday life which we
call classical physics for instance
where you are I expect to be in one
place at any one time the atoms in my
laboratory are perfectly happy to be in
two points at time a computer is a
physical system my laptop at home works
by pushing electrical signals around a
chip the computational power of that
device and the rules it follows are all
classical rules if you were the atom in
my laboratory you might wonder why
restrict me like that
why I would use classical rather than
these quantum rules I know and love and
that is a restriction there are problems
which we know scale as the problem size
gets bigger they scale exponentially on
a classical computer rapidly hitting the
edge of the universe where a quantum
computer would still be able to finish
in a reasonable amount of time
how and where does the quantum system
find its power in some sense it comes
from the fact that quantum computers can
process lots of inputs in parallel but
that has to be allowed to the ability to
combine these inputs and that happens
through the wave-like interference of
quantum mechanics and if we can do that
in these special ways combine these
answers or produce this interference of
a strong answer from lots of inputs then
we can make certain computations fast
one of those is in public key
distribution if we would be able to
break public key distribution and that's
a major security problem and so
governments have been interesting in
quantum computing since the 1990s but
other problems are available and one is
in calculating quantum systems
themselves so some of the molecules that
we have today for moco would be one of
them are quantum systems in themselves
and they are better done on a quantum
computer than a classical computer now
farmworker is interesting because it
allows plants to extract ammonia at
comfortable conditions and that's in
stark contrast to the industrial methods
we have today but quantum seems to be
possible in more areas and what we
firmly believe or I firmly believe is
that once people get hold of a quantum
computer they will think of new things
to do with it in 1940s people had
classical computers doing cryptography
and physics but now classical computers
do everything for us including your
smell
phone apps what would a quantum computer
look like well like here would look very
mundane it would be a supercomputer of
some type allotrope black boxes attached
to power into the network but it it's
heart a quantum computer has to have
quantum systems whether these be single
atoms single electrons currents in
superconductors or defects in some
material like diamond we don't yet know
what the winner is going to be of all of
these and we don't yet know when we're
going to get to that winner the systems
that I like to use are individual atoms
these are controlled using laser light
and the control we can achieve is
unmatched in its precision and these
have been used to make few quantum bit
quantum computers with five quantum bits
and about a thousand operation and in
the near future what we have coming is
50 to 100 quantum bits and that's
interesting for us in physics because a
classical computer would no longer be
able to compute what that system is
doing but we have a problem that the
lack of control will have over those
quantum systems means that probably we
won't be able to give you useful
computers at that scale conversely what
that's going to mean is we have to
actually make much larger systems if we
make larger systems we can correct
errors and that means that a useful
quantum computer probably means 1
million bits and 10 to the 17 operations
and that's a huge scaling beyond what we
have today so we have to take new
approaches in my field we go from
trapping systems to trap our atoms which
consists of machined metal to being
microchips that can be mass engineered
in which can integrate control and
that's something that we're working on
but there are challenges and this is
still a research challenge so one of the
challenges would be in optics
we have to deliver light to these atoms
to do our control lots of wonderful
optics exists at telecommunications
wavelengths 1550 nanometers but our
atoms are extremely specific about the
color of light that they interact with
so what we have to do is transfer all
these wonderful technologies down into
completely different range of colors
that needs new materials and it needs
new techniques but work is happening so
we see now ultraviolet fibers that have
been brought up from our quantum
computing community and chips now where
the light is guided through the chip to
do quantum control so this
really happening the quantum computer is
coming we don't know what form it will
take
ultimately I think we could safely say
that we don't know how long we're going
to take to get there but we should
remember that it's going to have power
beyond any computational device that we
have today a power which I think we
won't be able to fully utilize until the
children of tomorrow really start
playing with these systems thanks for
your attention
[Applause]